in Florida the Republican candidate for
governor is being accused of making
racist remarks yeah yeah governor of
Florida sounds like this guy wants to be
President
seriously anybody looking for yeah
that's the new qualification seeking of
which in a private meeting to get
support during the midterms president
Trump reached out to evangelical pastors
yeah an exchange Trump promised to only
sleep with Christian porn stars
that's the deal make sure everybody's
happy
what else going on yesterday President
Trump said Google is biased against him
Google yeah he said for example when I
googled Trump crime boss and impeachment
it brings up results for Trump crime
Boston impeachment he expects he expects
loyalty from algorithm yes from
algorithm exactly in a new interview
stormy Daniels said that President Trump
lasted less than two minutes in bed as a
result my wife is referring to me now as
presidential
I love that when I got sad they got sad
it's like a children's show I was happy
they were happy when I got setting her
[Music]
hey a new study just came out claims
that no no amount of alcohol is good for
you yeah yeah
in response Americans said do we look
like we want what's good for us
[Applause]
you